sometimes working early in the morning i
feel so afraid because it looks like a
peaceful place but it is the most
dangerous place
[Music]
here in kibera
we don't think about death because it
always happened
it was not my plan to give birth into
that community
[Music]
i feel so afraid raising my child
bad things happening around
they thought that marriage was the only
solution for my life after i gave back
[Music]
but for me i had my own thoughts
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you you know when gabby was five months
i went back to school
i was still breastfeeding him
[Music]
the teacher denied me like you can't go
back home so if you want to study you
have to leave that breastfeeding
[Music]
gabby used to wake up in the morning and
start crying sometimes we don't have
milk sometimes we don't have even
anything to give i had to make him
suffer to go back to school
[Music]
kibra is an informal settlement
we call it sometimes a chocolate city
because of the roofs when it's it's
raining it looks like chocolate
nowadays i hear people saying is one of
the biggest informal settlement in the
whole world because it's very rich in
cultures in
people who come from different tribes
and from different parts of this country
when there are so many people who are
all chasing good living condition they
have to work extra hard
within camera
children go through a lot but sometimes
schools help them to overcome some
children are in very abusive domestic
living conditions and schools used to
act as safe heaven for them because when
they're in school they're bit
out of their chaos that is happening for
them at home
our space
this is an after-school center it's a
safe house for children so children from
different schools come here to interact
and play together and also just be
children
we run programs the first one being the
arts program we do classical ballet
modern dance african dance
[Music]
okay
[Music]
i was born in poverty i never went to
school myself but i was able to find
myself
through dancing
i love the discipline
it
calmed me down it slowed me down it
tamed me
because it's about the body shape and so
i use it as the foundation for every
dance we do because it trains you your
inner self it trains your body
balak becomes the core
so you find the children they're always
present with their necks straight and
their back straight and when they train
that when they're still young
it's magic what you see
it gives you confidence you can stand in
a class and not know the answer and no
one will know because it gives you the
power of presence
i have been dancing ballet for five
years
it really inspired me
the dance gives me confidence and i
always feel like i'm top of the world
it's a little hard sometimes when you
can't get the steps correctly but me i
don't always give up i always try my
best until i get it right
sometimes girls face many challenges in
qibla but you have to believe in
yourself
and you have to be strong
and everything will be possible
we have a group of students coming in
from america today
they're coming in to just listen to us
and then go back home
hi i'm michael mayer and i'm a dance
teacher and also a social worker based
in cuba
so basically
i've been able to redesign the mindset
of dancing here
and
how we use dance because i think dance
is about solutions
to the community problems and not about
showcase and competition my students are
able to learn that and we've now grown
to this very powerful community here
where now
girls can speak and girls can shout
we run a sexually productive health and
rights program that supports mainly
adolescent girls with access to
menstrual products but also
training on leadership and also on
teenage pregnancy prevention
in between we do a lot of
talking and
mentorship
my office they are always like open for
children if you have an issue that you
want to address so whatever you have in
your mind you let us know and we will
all find a solution for it
we're going to do a big warm up
allah for tuanze
and now we're gonna reach to one side
evo in
our ballet program has a combination of
both boys and girls a majority being
girls
the girls depend on the boys to lift
them up
the girl has to shine five six seven go
you have to work so hard to lift that
gal up and that helps the boys to
understand that it's actually a
collective responsibility
in making the women rise
poverty has so many ways of disrupting
us but good education
can build resiliency in you
and so my aim is to use dance as a tool
to make children
have their self-realization to make
children know who they are and what they
want for their future and that
everything is in their hands
[Music]
when schools closed the first few months
we shut down
we were not able to sustain the rent
because we had no funding
our one day now they shifted focus into
like providing covered healthcare
equipment to their own country what do
you do
everything has to stop we struggled so
hard to just keep the space open because
we knew how important this space was for
our students
in qibla like people live on daily basis
so we wake up we make the money to eat
on that day then we go and sleep
so if we don't do it even one single day
it has a repercussion at the end of the
year
majority of our parents the ones i
directly work with they work in
middle-class people's houses
and so when the covered pandemic came in
almost 90 percent of our parents lost
their income
also children used to have access to a
meal in the school
but now when the schools were not there
the children were left to no meal at all
there were no peer support groups for
the young girls so they were way more
vulnerable i had girls who could not go
into their houses when their stepfathers
are there
or the person who is taking care of them
as their father is there because they
don't feel comfortable
the male people use it wrongly and they
take advantage of it by luring some of
these young girls with a bit of money
here and there and eventually for sexual
favors and then they dump them and run
away
in that covey period some of them ended
up pregnant and so the girls went out
and they found so many other young girls
who are pregnant and we started slowly
bringing them into this space and one
who walked in was winning
i got to knew mike when i was five
months pregnant i don't have a home i
don't have anywhere to go i don't have a
family so what can i do
mike told me you can't think about
abortion and you can't think about
killing yourself anymore i'm here to
help you and i'm here to support you so
take this money and go and eat something
he even called my mom one day started
telling her like no matter how hard it
is i know that in this society we need
to help each other we need to lift each
other so don't worry
mama winnie
don't worry it will be good
to me when a girl was pregnant
my biggest worry was
maternal death
i
reach out try to talk and find help and
promise them that we are together
because when they get pregnant they get
so ashamed of
themselves people would always brand a
teenage mother with failure
and that should not be the case because
the case should be
there is a mistake somewhere and we need
to solve something there is actually a
problem with all of us you know with the
entire community
and i just assured her like you know
what
we will stick together
[Music]
for me what i want is to go back to
school because i've seen how life is
hard here and without education
i can't do anything
one day
my hopes will come true and
that's me taking away my family from
that place
and giving them a better future it helps
me understand like they still life for
me
[Music]
the myth
and the whole mindset that we have here
that when a girl wakes up the first
thing they need to do is to make sure
that the whole house is clean before
they're able to even open a book
[Music]
that's hard but it is actually the
reality of the ground here
the housework is so much it's so
enormous that they don't even have time
to study
at home the choice that i have is to
wash the dishes clean the house
and wash my uniforms my siblings
uniforms yes
but i'm the girl i'm supposed to do the
work
i study to help my family i want to lift
my family up
and i also want to build my mum a big
house
she makes me believe in myself that i
can do it
when my mom doesn't have the tuition
money but i always stay at home so when
she gets the money she always gives me
the little she have and i always take it
to school
the beans is ready we are you just want
to start cooking for it but the water is
not as normal
we see a lot of outcomes in girls
we have guys who are now in university
and initially they never thought they
would get anywhere close to university
i have students who i used to teach when
they were very small and they now dance
in the us it opens up doors so it gives
you the pride because the moment you
realize who you are
nothing holds you back
nothing
he used to
hate staring porridge
like it was a punishment to me
because i'm grown up now i know how to
say it i feel so happy doing the
activity
the only person that i've met in my life
that believes in me it is only mike
and
i think my son too and i myself
michael tell me never give up never
never give up let us continue with the
journey it is just a rock it is just a
disruption in your way
my dream is to become a news anchor a
mentor a teacher and someone who can
help others in future
i want to see that be having a good
future and start to make gabby's
education look very light and make him
feel like he's someone's child
the father refused him maybe in future
he will never ask for that man
in his life he will just ask like
where's my mom i want to see my mom i
want to see that friend of mine who is
called my mom
go get porridge
now would you like a round too cynthia
what i want to do is i'm creating a
mindset of possibilities
no one will come from somewhere to solve
our problems
we have to face our problems and solve
them by ourselves because the solution
of our problems lies within us so
i
hope
i'm able to influence majority of my
students to think that way and that's my
biggest goal
i'm trying here everyone goes in now
listen up
we have our friends we're gonna do a
performance for them
so we have a production we're doing
we're gonna show you part of it which is
now called walks
yeah
[Music]
you part of a move in your head and you
come here and we practice it and it
becomes a very beautiful thing that
everybody claps for it that's innovation
and when children learn that from the
beginnings you can take the whole
concept and translate it into school
if i didn't know something yesterday
i i'll try my level best today and i
want to sit back and listen and follow
and when i'm now good at doing it i
reach out to somebody else who i see is
not able in doing it and show him how i
was shown and together we're rising
i always say you need to save other
people i need to raise other people but
understand that life you have to move on
you don't have to cry forever and you
know the time that you leave your
studies and say like i don't want to go
to school that is the end of your dream
that is the end of your benefit in the
city and that is the start of your
problems i need to tell other people
this is the solution that i did and you
need to do the same
you